[Music]
and do you know who I am knows oh [ __ ]
Rick got introduced you submitted by
your loyal fans since three years ago
for three never mind
after they wrote a teen went into a
furious rage after he failed to get a
woman's phone number
what are you picturing why are you
laughing I want to see what I'm
picturing a guy with the Pokemon shirt I
hate those dudes who get mad when you
hear no dominating guys where do you
where did you even buy this hat
that's a Pokemon hat either at Hot Topic
or spencer's oh you're one of those
people got you so I'm gonna have to
explain that to the kid kid mom go
shopping at a place that doesn't have
black white space for those aren't
rosary beads yeah we're talking about
you'll be like wait what happens yes
anyways so here is a video of this a
Mexican restaurant no this takes place
in Thailand oh I'm sorry you [ __ ]
racist bastard everyone just looks again
right you can't even see anyone I really
blurry I know I just see dark and thick
eyebrows I'm thinking maybe yeah maybe
but that could be like any ethnicity I'm
sorry beautiful brown just shut your
face okay whatever
all right so you're gonna see here so
first of all we're looking at the guy
with the gray shirt hey Jeff I'm not
sure who he's talking to here but it's
been reported that Roy wasabi was that
[Laughter]
it's been reported that his girlfriend
like he was with his girlfriend growing
wasabi was no no gray shirt gray shirt
oh yeah is that I don't know I can't see
gray shirt was with Chris go okay yeah
so we're looking at the gray shirt
and then he walks over to these girls
and we can't hear what you're saying but
pretty much she's trying to remember
he's with his girlfriend and then leaves
his girlfriend to talk to other girls
okay so it's been reported oh what a
scum no I got you yeah here we go
there's no sale so I guess they're
showing this just because this is like
the best view that they got of this guy
before he went over and attacked the
girls attack what yeah he flipped out so
he goes over to them telling them I can
give them a fake name and after like
trying to get the phone number after
they refused he was like don't you know
what who I am
I'm the son of a policeman Oh awesome
and then I don't know what they say back
to him
did something fall yeah so he pushed the
table yeah he pushed the table and her
her bowl of noodles fell on her net in
her lap I think she got some titties
though I mean breasts
she's quite voluptuous nothing I said
he's a [ __ ] betting yeah get the [ __ ]
away from then you scumbag this is
Tanner yeah
is that a [ __ ] what do you smell this
shirt that might be a [ __ ] yo what
the [ __ ] he's gonna get crazier bro
oh my god she oh she ain't taking [ __ ]
though yo she's kind of big yeah I think
that's an it Oh he suck oh she did it
muy Thai kick him oh damn you punched
her what the [ __ ] what
damn that's crazy oh he's choking her oh
my gosh well she's getting smaller now I
think it's Anglo bellick amaura girl you
better throw some hot Thai soup on him
or some [ __ ] ooh nice kick
you know I was wondering that too like
where is his girlfriend in all this girl
just fighting all over the restaurant
that's crazy I think they might have
seen his girlfriend earlier in the clip
cuz I saw somebody with long hair behind
him I expected Tony Jaa to just come in
somewhere I know start kicking some guy
yes and it's been confirmed that's what
started everything well that's what's
been reported
hmm so I'm not exactly sure but no
matter what the story spin was that's
just crazy dude let's just say they were
like [ __ ] you like that's still not okay
yeah yeah really physical I take a
rejection walk so it turned out that
this dude his name is Quinn 19 years old
my best plan so the policemen were
saying that they spoke to one of the
victims at the station and she was also
checked for injuries but it didn't seem
like she had any crazy injuries they're
also saying that this case was later
settled when the victim accepted ten
thousand thai baht which comes up to
about two hundred and eighty seven US
dollars three hundred bucks
why not could be a lot of money over
there it came from no dude he paid her
where did that money come from the dude
right there probably but they don't they
don't actually state that it seems like
it was done like under the table okay
fine here's like ten thousand baht yeah
because he's like the son of a policeman
yeah and the reason why she accepted the
compensation was because she wanted to
avoid prolonging the matter and
upsetting her boyfriend that's like oh
that sucks
I hate dudes that to do that they can't
just get a number based off their own
charm you gotta like figure out like oh
these are this is who I'm associated
with this is who my friends are and
they're just not good enough themselves
and then they get don't get man I heard
a story about a youtuber that did that
so they were out at a bar and so I know
this because my friend it happened to my
friend and she asked me if I knew who
these dudes weren't I know who they are
lightweight and basically the only dude
is two or three or four it's about two
guys boys do you guys know they came up
oh yeah they kind of came up and they
was like oh so have you heard of like
blah blah blah blah their youtube name
and she was like no not really
then she kind of knew but she's like I
said weird pickup lines like now he's
like oh well have you seen this video it
hit this amount of million views this
amount no joke and there's no not really
and then the do what goes away goes to
her friend ties to the same thing
all those her off comes back to was like
what you guys don't like like Chinese
guys or whatever like [ __ ] you get the
[ __ ] away from me like that's the most
looser a [ __ ] I've ever heard of my life
that's so funny because I do all that
was encountered by those guys as well
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah you're like I thought
you recognized me from this video it's
so cringy I know people who do that as
well I know people who do that in a
works though oh my god a little more
cringing to me that worked on a girl
rights like what look at your lowest
standards [ __ ] get your life together
I have these many followers I can make
you famous
and it works oh that's [ __ ] funny
before like one person here man
and I know multiple people who have said
things like that I know one person where
it worked and that person's in a
relationship no it's not him so a more
game than that because it's kind of like
it's like so that means up to this point
before you had a falling you will never
ever got a woman to talk to you yeah and
and they would brag about it like hawk
at this fine girl and I went up to where
I was just like my social blade that's
[ __ ] funny oh my goodness that's how
bad do you guys think you would step in
if you were witness to girls I would
have said [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her
are you okay unit is done one of these
hold on a second hold on hold on hold on
[Laughter]
oh yeah now you how do you just let that
go I know that's and then the fact that
they reported that his girlfriend was
right near near him and like that's just
happening maybe she's just like one of
those like girls that just likes him cuz
he has money or some [ __ ] but you know
what I did like though I like the fact
that those two girls were fighting back
yeah [ __ ] touch me I'll knock your
ass now she's doing noodles at him front
kick his ass [ __ ] she should've went for
the balls though mm-hmm you know nervin
in a fight but you never been in a fight
that's crazy
I thought Mexicans love fighting
we fought with our mouths re they fight
with their mouths and also you guys
should just fight them I would right now
right now because they're equal we have
a handicap oh I wouldn't fight a
pregnant lady no just put you in the
face only what if a pregnant it was
bound are you in yeah pregnant lady was
on top of me pounding me a wave and I'll
just be like well I must have deserve
this shape because I'm not hitting her
back you could've just like bumped into
our own accident well I'm almost what
are you talking about just fight but you
don't have more followers than all three
of us combined we all post it I'm pretty
sure a gr jail with fights no way she's
pregnant I guarantee you she I think she
quick for a kick be careful in the
fighting but if it's one of y'all I
would I had a [ __ ] grab this [ __ ]
I just want to put this in the story I
know how much how little she cares about
that child we've got a pool right and
there was a mosquito well I will show
you what this [ __ ] did so usually when
a mosquito comes or a bug comes or
something in the bucket at you will
protect your child first right miss
[ __ ] did this this mosquito came this
is her boss go kid she was trying to
protect it
the only one who caught it yeah you shut
up you were marching with me I want girl
get off me
No so okay what's the story
you look this fact I didn't go that walk
so those mosquitoes I was trying to get
right so that's going like this and then
it was coming close and I didn't think
it was the upper part you know what
that's just sound like a sheepskin drum
it's a dude that baby was like it's
gonna come out like this in the pool
they just want this inner Zoey's first
baby hope you guys enjoyed that episode
if you guys have any juicy little guts
of details and you guys want to submit
it well guess what you can cruise on
over to the description box below click
on the link submit the story and
hopefully we will pick it and talk about
it for more videos click right over here